la situación en la ciudad de jerson se
deteriora con las horas como ya lo había
anunciado en su intervención de la noche
de ayer el presidente bolodominis
selensky el número de misiles que caen
sobre la ciudad cada vez son mayor ayer
por ejemplo en uno de los distritos
cercanos a la estación de tren donde
todos los días llegan cientos de
personas tratando de dejar la ciudad
cayó uno de estos misiles dejó cinco
personas muertos esto solamente en la
noche y estamos en una de las plazoletas
a la entrada de la ciudad estás
absolutamente necesaria pasar por aquí
cuando se viene de la ciudad de Nicolás
y aquí también está muy cerca el
supermercado la única gran superficie
abierta en la ciudad de que desde días
atrás provee de alimentos a los
habitantes de gerson hemos visto en las
últimas días filas y filas de personas
esperando acceder a productos básicos Y
aquí mismo cayeron estos dos misiles uno
en el medio de la otro en un edificio
cercano donde estos es bomberos y
integrantes de Los cuerpos de seguridad
de Jesús están tratando desde espinar y
Desactivar Así que la situación cada vez
es más complicada y de allí que cientos
de personas en las últimas horas
empiecen a abandonar a jerson ya no lo
hacen por la falta de Electricidad o por
la falta de agua o la escasez de
calefacción ahora que hace tanto frío
sino por esos ataques continuos que como
queda demostrado tienen como objetos
cercanías donde está la población civil